it's like this layer of dimensional
reality and it seems to manipulate
space-time I call it the speed force
caused me to burn a tremendous amount of
calories I'm just a black hole of snacks
I am a snack hole
[Music]
battery
hey everybody its charlie they finally
confirmed they're moving forward with
the flashpoint movie there's a bunch of
details that have been confirmed so I
wanted to do an update video and I got a
lot of questions about what it's going
to be is it gonna be like a Justice
League film is it gonna be just a flash
by himself thankfully we know about some
of the foundational aspects and we have
some details about how they're treating
each of the movies being connected to
each other like what that's going to
look like going forward so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
gonna be so much awesome Titan stuff
coming up along with Young Justice
season 3 do you guys have no idea it's
gonna be great
but I know there are a lot of big movie
questions so first big detail like the
thing that was just confirmed the thing
everybody's going crazy about is is that
they confirmed that the people who wrote
spider-man homecoming not the director
but the writers of spider-man homecoming
are going to write in direct the
flashpoint movie meaning that if you
heard details about the movie about how
Captain Cold was supposed to be the main
villain along with some of the rogues
and reverse flashes involvement was
gonna be a little bit different from
what the comic book flashpoint looked
like that a lot of that could be
changing because the directors are gonna
get a rewrite on it so in the way that
there was like a Batman script that Ben
Affleck and Geoff Johns did before Matt
Reeves was hired and then as part of his
deal he got the opportunity to rewrite
that script so like it wasn't that
Deathstroke raid movie that it was going
to be originally it's gonna be the same
thing with a flashpoint movie so like
there been a couple drafts of the script
in the past couple years just forget
about all that stuff the biggest change
I think is in what the tone is going to
be like oh wow they just they really
just vanish oh that's rude so when you
heard about the flashpoint movie back
when like that maybe Superman and
Justice League we're at Comic Con I
think it was leaning in a much darker in
Justice Z direction so everything had
this very injustice pallor about it
Captain Cold looked way freakish
compared to the comic book version of
himself like imagine the nightmare
versions of all these characters that
you've been reading for so long so we
think the big message of last year the
success of Wonder Woman the problems
with Justice League just made them lean
back in a more classic comic book II
direction so the flash does kind of read
like Spider Man on the page so it makes
sense that they would go with the
directors that did a successful
spider-man movie
he's a wise core
he's relatively hopeful even though
really dark things happened to him you
know that I was the only one who
believed he knew everyone else said I
was crazy to recruit a 14 year old kid
I'm 15 no this is where your zip it all
right the adult is talking what if
somebody had died tonight different
story right cuz that's on you and if you
died so if you've never read the
flashpoint story or you haven't seen the
animated movie or another version of it
it's a story all about learning to deal
with loss and grieve like if there are
things about your life that you don't
like and you have the power of a Living
God
should you use that power and how does
that power affect other people that's
also kind of an idea that they've
threaded with the Superman character in
the DC movies since Man of Steel like
what is the consequence of a living God
being on earth so the flesh does have
the power of a god it's just that he's
such a young person that you don't think
of him that way but he really is one of
the most powerful people on the earth so
what about release date if they just
confirmed the directors that means that
they probably turned in a draft like on
a pitch just like here's some bullet
points about what we would do with this
story so they already have an idea for
what that's going to be next step is
actually writing the movie and starting
to cast the rest of the characters I
don't know if they're gonna keep their
iris west or if they're gonna recast her
there was like a whole big thing during
Justice League where they tried to
delete some footage in case they wanted
to recast her in the future so who knows
what's gonna happen with that but they
have to cast their rogues they have to
cast their reverse-flash but there was a
rumor circulating that they were gonna
make him a more minor character in their
version of flashpoint and it was going
to be more of the Rogues being the big
bad so his mostly flash versus Rogues
with a little bit of reverse flash off
in the distance cackling and delight
because he is the person that killed
Barry's mother you can't do flash point
without reverse flash
I've notified STAR Labs to ready a cozy
little cell for you professor I
understand the food's not great there
zoom enjoy your petty little victories
flash but no matter how fast you run you
can't save everyone not the ones that
matter to you but to answer the question
about Justice League movie or just a
flash movie with cameos from Justice
League members I actually do think that
it's just gonna be a flash movie with
Justice League involvement so you have
Superman Wonder Woman and Batman cameos
but for the most part it will feel like
a smaller version of comic book
flashpoint because that really was like
a line wide thing where you had every
single DC character and that would
basically be them doing it Justice
League sequel and I don't think they're
ready to do that because the spider-man
homecoming people that they hired to do
this aren't like the Russos they just
don't have the experience in wrangling
movies that are that big so I think
they're trying to opt for a smaller film
but because the movies on gal gadot
contract it's on Ben Affleck's contract
it would be like his last DC movie
unless he resigns a brand new contract
Henry Cavill still has another movie on
his contract same thing with a cyborg
character and they're still committed to
making a cyborg film so imagine like a
smaller version of Civil War
so like Civil War was a Captain America
film it was driven by his character but
there were a lot of other Avengers in it
so people jokingly called it Avengers
2.5 so you wouldn't be wrong to call it
Justice League 1.5 because they'll be
dealing with Justice League things but
it sounds like it's gonna be largely
localized to Central City instead of
being like this big worldwide thing that
it was in the comics or the animated
movie speaking of worldwide I almost
forgot to mention
Aquaman we have the Aquaman movie coming
up we haven't had a trailer for that yet
you see would be a very small part of
flashpoint if you're gonna do cameos
with the other Justice League members
but he's not quite as critical if you're
not gonna do that full blown worldwide
flashpoint so the flash is like the baby
of the team you have to imagine that he
goes through this experience in Wonder
Woman and Superman are characters that
can help give him advice like look Barry
you need to learn to deal with this
grief
but largely it's driven by the Flash's
story so I'm not expecting to see like a
nightmare version of Superman because if
you've heard about all those Justice
League deleted scenes they tried to do
that and just decided that they didn't
want to go down that route so I don't do
they're gonna double down on nightmare
Superman during flashpoint when it comes
to reverse flash though I think they're
taking more of the Shazam black atom
approach where like they're making the
Shazam movie right now but black Adam
isn't the main villain to that he's a
character that's gonna be involved with
it in some way but only a minor way and
then they'll build up to like a big
confrontation down the road if that
first Shazam movie is successful like
eventually you have to address Black
Adam in that universe even if you don't
want to deal with them right away so
it's the same deal with reverse flash
the main concern with DC movies right
now isn't just doing really awesome
characters like nailing the flash once
they get a really awesome version of the
flash on screen then they can blow it up
into something bigger so there are core
things about the flash that you have to
include in that like the reverse flash
STAR Labs his relationships with the
other Justice League members but beyond
that I think they're gonna try and keep
the movie relatively small just so that
it doesn't get out of control the way
Justice League did just because that got
so big take it slow one step at a time
make all the running puns you can think
of and that says nothing of what's going
on in the TV universe like we have
Titans coming up we have Wally West on
legends of tomorrow there's all the
stuff on the main flash TV show so
there's a lot of big flash stuff coming
up all over the place but if you're not
a big comic book reader there's actually
this really cool thing that they're
getting ready for called flash war it is
basically the flash family fighting with
itself primarily centered on the ginger
version of Wally West that came back
after DC rebored so that's separate from
what's happening in the movies I'll do
videos for because obviously I do flash
videos every week but leave all your
requests in the comments below for
everybody asking about the Batman movie
Matt Reeves did confirm that he's still
riding it right now so I'm assuming that
all the rumors that he's leaving are not
true it's just that some of the movies
had been back-burnered like the
Nightwing movie isn't a big priority so
the director of the night way movie is
still in the DC Universe it's just that
he's gonna go off and make another movie
before he does Nightwing so it's gonna
be like 2023 before we see it so Bay
on the pace that things are moving along
Batman movie in three to four years
Nightwing movie the year after that
Batman movie drops because of course
you're gonna want to drop a Nightwing
movie right after you drop a new version
of Batman but if we get any more updates
on that stuff I'll do videos about it
but for the most part the other DC
movies you heard about Aquaman Wonder
Woman tooth are all going along fine so
no worries there there are a couple
videos that I'm working on so just check
my top pin comment to find out what I'm
working on next so click here for brand
new flash and Titans and click here for
brand new infinity war to learn about
those phase four movies they just
announced thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome see you guys
tonight